-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How is everybody doin' tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
Former President George W. Bush
spoke about Russia last night
at an event in Dallas
and had quite the Freudian slip.
-The decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of Iraq --
I mean, of Ukraine.
[ Laughter ]
-Oof!
That's like your wife
asking if you're hungry
and saying, "I could cheat.
I mean, eat!"
[ Laughter ]
"I could eat with my mistress.
Aghh!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday
launched a program
that activates military aircraft
to import baby formula
from abroad.
Said the French, "White or red?"
[ Laughter ]
Health Secretary Xavier Becerra
tested positive yesterday
for the coronavirus.
Wow, the health secretary.
That's embarrassing.
That's like finding out
the transportation secretary
got hit by a train.
[ Laughter ]
He's fine. He's fine.
President Biden yesterday
formally endorsed
Finland and Sweden's application
to join NATO.
Though if it's anything
like his past endorsements,
it probably hurt
more than it helped.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Secret Service
is currently providing
protection for 33 people
in the Biden administration
or family,
as opposed to to Trump,
where his administration
was his family.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk tweeted yesterday,
"Political attacks on me
will escalate dramatically
in coming months."
And based on
his previous predictions,
this can only mean
that political attacks on him
will stop completely.
[ Laughter ]
Health officials
in Massachusetts
announced yesterday
that they have identified
the first case of monkeypox
in the country.
But don't worry,
it can be easily cured
with, uh -- aw, baby formula!
Damn it!
[ Laughter ]
Son of a bitch!
The 75th Cannes Film Festival
began this week
and included
a live video message
from Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy.
But this is weird.
It was just,
"Please don't text
during the movie."
[ Laughter ]
A 2-year-old boy in Texas
recently ordered
31 cheeseburgers from McDonald's
through the delivery app
DoorDash
while playing
with his mom's phone.
To be fair, in Texas,
That's just one button.
[ Cheers and laughter ]
And finally,
the makers of Hot Pockets
have unveiled a new line of
cheese and cold cut sandwiches
called Deliwiches
that can be eaten hot or cold,
as opposed to Hot Pockets,
which are always a mix of both.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.